[dramatic music]
Cameras aren't working.
That's getting
super frustrating.
MAN 1: This is what it's
like on "Life Below Zero."
NATHANIEL STEPHENS:
Camera's already down.
Tough conditions all
around to film in.
CROFTON DIACK: No heat,
no power, no anything.
[groans]
Won't even turn on.
CROFTON DIACK: I've
fallen too many times.
We have bad winds and it's just
a typical day in the Arctic.
NATHANIEL STEPHENS: Making
the best of what we got.
[serene music]
This is an exciting time
getting ready for our big trip
in the most remote
location you can think of.
CROFTON DIACK: Wow.
The cache is still standing.
MAN 1: This is just one
of our cycles in the year.
The time to come
down here is now.
We're getting ready to
follow the Hailstones out
to their hunting
grounds in Kiwalik.
We're here in Noorvik right now,
so that's about 90 miles away
by snowmachine, so there's a lot
of prep that goes into getting
ready for the journey.
A lot of things up here when
we're filming in the winter
start with digging.
This CONEX trailer where
we store our gear here
Noorvik has pretty well
drifted in with snow.
Hoping to get it dug out and
get one of our sleds out so
I can load it up and
start the packing process
for our big trip to Kiwalik.
So I've get the
door cleared out.
And hopefully, it should be
enough clearance to open it up
and get the sled out of here.
Seems like we have
a frozen lock.
That happens from time to time.
I think some water got into
the mechanism of the lock
and froze.
Just putting a little bit of
lighter heat on it in the past
has worked pretty well for us.
See if that'll do the trick.
[triumphant music]
Yes.
Got it.
All right.
Here's the sled I
was looking for.
So this is our crew flat sled.
It's very similar to a sled
that the Hailstones use to move
their gear around as well.
Pretty common in this area for
moving stuff in the wintertime.
In addition to keeping the
crew safe and well-fed,
my role on the crew is
taking care of logistics.
So when we go out and
do a remote shoot,
it's my job to make sure we have
everything we need to set up
a little city that
we can live and work
out of when we're out there.
I can't run down to the corner
store if I forget something,
so I need to make sure I've got
everything that we need to set
up a comfortable little
tent city where we can live,
and eat, and sleep, and work,
and enjoy ourselves as well
out there.
So this is something
that we use whenever
we're working remotely.
It's a big heavy-duty
double wall canvas tent.
It weighs a ton, but
it's really ready
for an arctic environment.
It can handle big wind.
It's a good spot to set up all
of our camera equipment inside,
also to set up a kitchen.
That's where the crew
hangs out and sleeps,
so it's really important that we
have something good for tents.
Hailstones like to move around
depending on where the game is
or what the story
is we're working on.
I need to also be ready to set
up a mobile camping situation.
Heat is going to be really
important out there.
I've got a couple
different systems for that.
A very crucial part of our gear
here is this gas generator.
Electricity is very important
when you're making television.
Obviously, we have to charge
all of the camera batteries
and keep all of the other
equipment functioning.
This is our toilet.
And we practice leave no trace
camping out there, which means
we want to leave the Arctic
environment just like we
found it or even better.
So we pack it in and
we pack it all out,
including our human waste.
And I put a little foam seat on
there to keep everyone's butt
warm in 30 below.
I packed a lot of
food ahead of time.
When we're out spending a long
day filming and then coming
back to camp, it's not always
practical to make a big dinner,
so I've prepared a lot of meals
ahead of time and frozen them.
And they'll travel
out with us and make
the cooking job a little bit
easier once we get out there.
So I've gone through the list.
I've got all my essentials.
I'm going to pack all this stuff
along with our personal gear
and all of our camera
gear on our four sleds,
and we're going to head out for
our big journey to the Kiwalik
following the Hailstones.
CROFTON DIACK: We're
Eagle Crew out.
I think this is
our last year load.
[tense music]
MAN 2: It's fascinating to watch
the workings of mother nature
on this massive river
throughout the year.
MAN 3: When you live out
here, we don't have roads.
In Alaska, most of the rivers
are the-- are the highways,
and we live along an interstate.
[relaxing music]
Our last ride is
with the helicopter,
so we're going to
sling all of our stuff
over to the bluff 16 miles
downstream on the Yukon River,
which is frozen right now, and
then head it to camp and film
the ice breakup.
This is all of our supplies
for the next two weeks.
[grunts]
That's already
200, 300 pounds.
CROFTON DIACK:
Let's keep loading
and wait for this helicopter.
MAN 4: Thank you.
500 pounds of
gear ready to go.
[helicopter whirring]
MAN 4: I think those
are going to go inside.
There goes the load.
Aye, aye, aye.